code is capable of encoding M cubits so the code space has Dimension 2 the m and its distance is D so an error has to
have weight weit D or more to change the logical state of whatever Cubit we've been coded without being detected as an
error we'll now take a look at the 7 Cubit steam code as an example and we'll determine what its distance
is here are the stabilizer generators for this code and recall that the distance is the minimum weight of an
encubate poly operation that commutes with all of the stabilizer generators but is itself not in the stabilizer nor
is it proportional to an element of the stabilizer what we'll determine is that this code has distance
three the way that we'll determine this is to First consider any poly operation having weight at most two and we'll
conclude that the only way that it can compute with all six stabilizer generators is for to be the identity which is always an element of the
stabilizer so let's suppose that the possibly non-identity polym matricies that form this operation which we'll
call P and Q appear in the leftmost two positions this is just one case and we do have to
consider all of the other possible locations for these possibly non-identity poly matrices but the argument is basically the same for all
of the possible locations well by assumption this operation commutes with all sticks
stabilizer generators so in particular it commutes with this one and it also commutes with this
one Q lines up with the identity Matrix in both of these generators which is why we chose these two and we have identity
Matrix IES in the rightmost five positions of this error and so we conclude that P must commute with both x
and z because otherwise this error would anticommute with one of these two generators but the only polymatrix that
commutes with both x and z is the identity so P must be the identity and now that we know that we
can choose two more stabilizer generators that have an X and a z in the second position from left and we can
draw a similar conclusion about Q so there's no way for a weight atmost 2 error to go undetected by this code
unless it's just the identity operation which is in the stabilizer so this isn't actually an
error on the other hand there are weight three poly operations that commute with all six of these stabilizer generators
but aren't proportional to stabilizer elements and here are two examples so we've concluded that this
code has distance three the last thing that we'll discuss in this lesson is correcting errors for
stabilizer codes as usual we'll assume our code is specified by nbit stabilizer generators
P1 through p and let's start by thinking a little bit about all of the possible errors that could take
place there are two to the r possible syndromes and as I mentioned earlier in the lesson these syndromes partition all
of the possible en cupit poly operations into equal siiz collections so that means 4 the N / 2 the r poly operations
within each set so when we see a particular syndrome it could be that any one of these four to the N divided by 2
to the r errors is responsible we are overcounting a little bit here though because some of these
errors have exactly the same effect on the code space in particular if we have an error E and we multiply e By Any
stabilizer element s then we're going to get another error that has exactly the same effect in the code space as e so
these are equivalent errors the stabilizer has two to the r elements and if we account for this then we find
that for each syndrome there are four to the N minus r INE equivalent classes of errors that could have caused that one
syndrome and what that means is that unless R is equal to n in which case we have a one-dimensional code space and
therefore can't encode any cubits at all it's not going to be possible to correct every error that we can detect instead
what we have to do is choose just one correction operation for each syndrome in the hopes of correcting just one class of equivalent
errors so how should we choose what correction to perform for each syndrome a natural strategy is to choose
the lowest weight poly operation that causes whatever syndrome we measure with the idea being that lower weight poly
operations represent more likely explanations for that syndrome this might not actually be the
case for some noise models and another natural strategy is to somehow compute the most likely error that causes the
given syndrome but for now we'll just consider the strategy where we attempt to correct errors by selecting the lowest weight poly operation causing the
syndrome for a distance D stabilizer code this strategy will always allow us to correct errors having weight strictly
less than half of D or in other words weight at most D minus1 over2 and I'll explain briefly why this
is this will show for instance that the 7 Cubit steam code can correct for any weight one poly error and by the
discretization of errors this means that just like the 9 Cubit Shore code the steam code can correct for an arbitrary
error on one cubit so here's how this works consider that this circle represents all of the possible poly
operations that result in the all plus1 syndrome which is the syndrome that suggests that no errors have occurred
and nothing is wrong among these operations we have elements of the stabilizer or really
operations that are proportional to elements of the stabilizer and we also have non-trivial errors that change the code space somehow but they aren't
detected by the code and We Know by the definition of distance that every poly operation in this category must have weight at least
D because D is defined as the minimum weight of these operations we also have poly operations
that cause other syndromes to appear and we could consider each syndrome in turn if we wish but here we're just imagining
that one such syndrome s has appeared now imagine that e is an eror in this
category that has weight strictly less than half of the distance D well we don't know that this is
necessarily the minimum weight poly operation in this circle so let's take C to be the minimum weight operation in this set or one of them in case there's
a tie so it could be that c is equal to e or possibly not but because C has
minimum weight we know that it can't possibly have weight larger than the weight of E because C is also in the set
and it has minimal weight so the correction operation C must have weight strictly less than half of
D so what happens if we apply this correction C to whatever our state becomes after the air e
occurs the answer is that the state that we obtain is C * e multiplied to the original encoding because we first
multiply by E that was the error and then we multiplied by C to try to correct it and this product must be in